le
procès
avoir été
un
bon soir
bon la moitié la présentation a été
faite
je m'appelle donc françois grave et j'ai
29 ans
presque je suis marié j'ai deux enfants
de petite chatte est un gros chien et je
suis heureux heureux également d'être
avec vous ce soir et comme toi c'est
fini je partage ce rêve de participer à
tmx parce que j'ai toujours rêvé d'avoir
un micro cravate a les crocs madonna
parlons c'est toujours un micro comme ça
à l'école
là j'ai l'impression d'être une
une vraie chanteuse une vraie star alors
vous l'avez compris on va parler ce soir
de marketing non ne partez pas tout de
suite ce n'est pas que un gros mot et je
trouve qu'il ya une certaine ironie ou
du sort de présenter cette conférence à
sciences po parce qu'avec
politiciens marketeurs et peut-être
garagiste je crois qu'on tient le trio
de tête des métiers qui sont
particulièrement honni mais non c'est
tout à fait injuste on ne mérite pas ce
que ce que l'on a envie mais pourtant
c'est vrai
du marketing c'est que du marketing
marketing politique etc
vous l'avez entendu mille fois 7 durant
de même cette campagne électorale alors
on va parler de marketing mais peut-être
commencer déjà par définir le terme qui
est trop mal trop souvent mal connues
alors victor pas paniquer un grand
designer hongrois akli on doit cette
définition le marketing étant l'art de
persuader des personnes d'acheter des
produits dont ils n'ont pas besoin avec
l'argent qu'ils n'ont pas pour
impressionner des voisins qui s'en
moquent
merci victor alors bon d'un autre côté
victor planète s'est fait connaître par
le design de cette chaise donc si
j'étais lui je les ramènerai pas trop
non plus
le maire treating bon c'est un terme
anglais et on va faire appel plutôt à la
langue française qui est si précise qui
permet de donner du sens bien mieux avec
les mots l'assemblée de l'assemblée de
l'assemblée quand même est en tout cas
l'académie française nous a proposé
cette version du terme marketing avec un
mot à la fois chic et élégant
qui est la marque éthique
alors mercatique par contre a quand même
un gros avantage c'est qu'il permet de
remonter aux sources et vous allez
retrouver
le mercato le marché dont tout le monde
connaît la définition revenait en
seconde c'est le lieu de rencontre entre
l'offre et la demande merci et puis il
ya le hic le suffixe ict qui rattachait
aussi ronsard les mathématiques la
science physique histoire géographie
physique oui l'histoire géographique
donc la mercatique finalement c'est quoi
c'est la science du marché n'allons pas
chercher plus loin n'allons pas chercher
plus compliqué
chaque chaque prof de marketing a sa
propre définition évidemment mais celle
ci paraît quand même très très simple et
restons restons sur le plus simple la
science du marché c'est
la capacité de comprendre à marcher
d'agir sur un marché et à cliquer à
l'entreprise on comprend tout de suite à
ça donne du sens au département
marketing à ce qu'on appelle les
marketeurs s'agit de mieux comprendre le
marché sur lequel on opère de choisir et
d'avoir des éléments de choix dans la
stratégie
ce que vous voulez définir sur ce marché
évidemment agir sur ce marché donc
choisir
comprendrechoisir agir les trois mots
principaux d'un marketeurs et de ce que
la science du marché nous avons
par exemple
ou à l'ultime vision de l'éthique en
marketing
que j'aime beaucoup
oui bien sûr
si on est si mal aimés si on est si
caricaturer c'est que peut-être
on y est pour quelque chose et vous avez
entendu certainement de nombreux
reportages ou vu à la télé de nombreux
reportages sur le marketing les
entreprises qui se comportent de plus en
plus mal pas plus tard que merck jeudi
soir cash investigations consacré son
émission sur mac donald's et la façon
dont mcdonald's organise son marché
évidemment on se dit mais qu'est ce que
vous êtes qu'est ce que vous apportez à
la société alors
face à ça
peut-être que certains d'entre vous ont
même entendu commence à entendre en tout
cas de plus en plus des mots comme du
marketing positif du marketing
responsable du marketing attention
éthiques
bon alors à ce moment de la conférence
je préférais tout de suite être clair
c'est des foutaises
il n'y a pas de marketing positif il n'y
a pas de marketing responsable je vous
le dis le marketing est une science
une science n'est ni bonne ni mauvaise
les mathématiques sont pas gentils
vous avez pas de la biologie terrifiante
où des la philosophie responsables non
marketing c'est la marque était par
contre la façon dont on fait du
marketing
là peut être
positives ou négatives
l'éthique définit ce que l'on fait
défini la visée alors je vous encourage
à lire paul ricoeur qui a un grand
sociologue et philosophe français de la
fin du xxème siècle
qui a été des acteurs de l'université de
nanterre dans les années 60 je sens
qu'il
est qu'il y a qui a écrit un livre
assez intéressant sur les tickets qui
propose pour la première fois une vision
différence entre la morale ce que vous
allez entendre peut-être souvent parler
de morale et d'éthique ce sont deux
notions alors deux mots qui viennent
l'un du latin morales de l'autre du grec
et os et qui définissent tous les deux
la même chose c'est-à-dire les moeurs
mais on va adopter une vision plutôt
alors je suis à sciences po
aristotélicienne
et paul ricoeur va proposer de dire la
morale est ce que l'on s'interdit permet
de définir ce que l'on va s'interdire de
faire dans une société sont les dix
commandements ce sont les principes de
conduite et les tic va il va définir les
tic comme étant la visée d'une vie
remplie ou destinés au bien et c'est
cette définition là qui est intéressante
et cette subtilité qui est intéressante
rentrer le code of conduct le moral on
en a les seins cachés oui j'ai essayé
l'année riscle
l'éthique où il n'y a pas cette nuance
finalement on américains ou anglais
l'éthique la définir non parce qu'on n'a
pas le droit de faire mais plutôt
pourquoi on le fait et est-ce qu'on va
vers une vis des du bien du bien et tu
en as bien général ou un bien
spécifique dans sur un marché alors
retenez bien ça c'est vraiment le
message principal n'y a pas de marketing
négatif ou responsables il ya que des
marketeurs positif ou responsables et
est responsable
on le voit c'est aussi le symbole d'une
d'un changement dans la société ce
chiffre de 84 %
c'est une étude bva en 2000
2021 donc ça allait vraiment récente
l'institut bbva fait une enquête sur le
comportement des français et la façon
dont ils réagissent par rapport aux
marques et 94 84% des français
affirment pouvoir abandonner marquis
qu'il ne jugerai pas avoir des
comportements responsables des tic ou
moralement acceptable
c'était un chiffre qui était de l'ordre
de 70% il ya juste en 2015 donc on voit
en l'espace de six ans l'évolution de la
société et l'exigence des consommateurs
vers des entreprises de plus en plus à
les responsables
le 2e chiffre aussi d'intéressants s'il
avait beaucoup plus important que en
2015 on n'était pas du tout en ces
heures de grandeur 62 % ces dix seront
les le pourcentage des français ils sont
prêts à tester des produits responsables
c'est ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
changer leurs habitudes de consommation
vers des produits éventuellement promis
pour être plus positif plus responsable
et ça c'est un énorme changement et une
crainte absolument terrible pour les
entreprises puisque elles risquent de
perdre leur base de clients c'est à dire
ceux qui sont pour ceux pour qui ils
travaillent et l'essentiel le revenu
donc le risque majeur c'est de voir
partir leurs clients ou qui voudraient
tester des produits plus plus
responsable vous l'avez probablement
tous et toutes déjà expérimentée depuis
quelques années on parle de produits
cosmétiques
responsable on à du savon solide on a
des shampoings
solide en at-il
qui sont là pour répondre à des attentes
de consommateurs
alors je vais prendre ma casquette de
marketer quand même
tout ça c'est bien mais une bonne pub à
la télé une bonne collaboration
avec lui en ce cas les 30 % de réduction
et toutes ces belles promesses
ne se concrétiseront pas nécessairement
on a des armes pour ça non ce qui pose
vraiment un problème est ce qu'il ya à
mon avis de manière un peu plus cyniques
va expliquer pourquoi des entreprises se
retourne donc se tourner vers des
solutions plus responsable et plus
éthiques malheureusement c'est à cause
de ce chiffre
44 % 44 % c'est un millénium sur deux
vous
jeunes 1 milliard sur deux déclare avoir
déjà refusé un job ou une opportunité de
travail
parce que le sort ne partageait plus les
valeurs de l'entreprise vous ne partagez
pas les valeurs de l'entreprise pour
lesquels il était destiné et ce chiffre
là est absolument
fondamental ce chiffre là fait peut-être
et courait ce qu'on entend un peu en ce
moment dans la presse où il ya une
difficulté
de recrutement les entreprises ont de
plus en plus de mal à recruter des
jeunes en particulier parce que là là il
va l'être bien payés ils veulent avoir
des horaires normaux et en plus ils
veulent que nos entreprises soient
responsables et voire même éthique un
cynisme mise de côté c'est un véritable
enjeu majeur pour les dr les directions
des ressources humaines dans les
entreprises d'avoir ce qu'on va appeler
une marque employeur ça c'est à dire
d'avoir une marque une entreprise qui va
rés des collaborateurs et en particulier
les mini et rolls vers des valeurs
partagées et les valeurs positives à
partager
alors bon je peux pas m'en empêcher
voilà la terreur de toutes les
entreprises et tous les chefs
d'entreprise évidemment élise lucet pour
les anglo saxons c'est
puisqu'on n'est pas d'ailleurs en
angleterre aussi aux états unis si allah
l'équivalent de notre élite nationale
mais c'est véritablement une peur pour
les entreprises d'être cité dans le hall
of shame
d des entreprises avec des mauvais
comportements et bien sûr il ya une
pression supplémentaire qui a été mise
sur les entreprises d'être reconnus ou
désignés comme non éthiques ou non
responsable
bon c'est bien mais qu'est ce qu'on en
fait de tout ça et c'est vraiment la
question puisque aujourd'hui 11 par
corruption on lance cette étincelle on
essaie d'être d'allumer cette étincelle
de la révolution je vais revenir juste
peut-être
sur ce chiffre
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait on pourrait le
voir de manière assez positif comme je
les présenter à titre personnel je le
trouve très inquiétant très inquiétant
imaginons simplement que sur ces 44 %
de jeunes millénium ce qu'ils refusent
de travailler dans une entreprise
à derek des comportements négatifs
imaginez simplement 6 1%
ne refusez pas l'obstacle
rester dans ces entreprises et 10 non
de l'intérieur non nous ne continuerons
pas avoir ces comportements non je ne
veux pas continuer je veux continuer à
travailler chez vous parce que j'aime
cette entreprise j'aime travailler
j'aime le produit qu'on vend mais non je
ne veux pas continuer à faire ça
imaginez simplement la puissance que
cela pourrait avoir
de transformation de ce que
j'appellerais la transformation éthique
des entreprises
j'ai travaillé pendant 20 ans dans un
groupe pétrolier je l'avais pas dit ça
je m'en fous
oui bien sûr le pétrole ont leur on le
sait c'est s'est pas vraiment
l'avenir et on sait tous que ça peut
causer et est-ce que plutôt milliards
dans des pétroliers mais champs
pétroliers on pourrait pas déjà essayer
de faire changer les choses de
l'intérieur c'est là où on est le mieux
placé
ce n'est pas simplement du temps
activistes à l'extérieur on peut être un
activiste à l'intérieur des entreprises
c'était le premier point le deuxième
point
peut-être que vous l'avez lu il ya
quelques années c'était fans et celle
avait sorti un petit guide il s'appelait
indignez vous
non je sais pas si ça vous parle c'était
pour 3 euros et vous pouvez l'acheter
c'était vraiment un manifeste
particulièrement fort qui essayer de
remobiliser la jeunesse est d'ailleurs
lui les moins jeunes ont 29 ans
pour que tu rigoles
et
qu'ils aient indignez vous lever vous
n'ayez pas peur
vous avez le droit de vous indignés
alors le marché a répondu en créant les
réseaux sociaux et donc on s'indigne sur
internet on s'indigne sur un stage sur
twitter
mais quand est-ce qu'on passe à l'action
j'aurais aimé maintenant parler plutôt
de actionner vous
agissez
ne vous ennuyez pas simplement agissait
et pour terminer cette journée merci de
cette organisation ça a été vraiment
passionnant ce tous les intervenants et
dès ce matin en fait un avec la crise
des opioïdes qui était donc il était
assez bouleversant mais derrière ces
opioïdes il ya des entreprises
c'est pas les entreprises qui sont
méchantes sepa mckinsey qui a été le
conseil de cette entreprise pendant des
années qui est méchant
mauvais ce sont les collaborateurs qui
est à l'intérieur de ces entreprises qui
ne sont pas des entreprises à
l'intérieur de ces entreprises ont
décidé de sa stratégie ont décidé de
mentir ont décidé de mettre en place
comme ce matin on a vu des
stratégies pour rendre leurs
consommateurs addict malgré le risque
alors agir c'est facile c'est facile de
le dire sur une scène c'est facile de
leader dans une salle de cours
je parle même faire un petit livre ça
serait encore plus facile
mais yade bon alliage ya un truc qui moi
m'a aidé beaucoup et que je voudrais
transmis transmettre un petit truc
essayez de
de penser à la personne
pour laquelle vous avez la plus grande
bienveillance plus grand amour la plus
grande bienveillance est là qui vous ne
pourriez pas faire de mal
essayez d'imaginer cette personne de
visualiser cette personne allait
peut-être chercher dans votre dans vos
albums photos
la photo de votre grand-père ou la photo
de votre cousine ou autre
et dites-vous en la regardant lorsque
vous travaillez sur un plan un business
plan lorsque vous travaillez sur des
politiques pour vous messieurs dames de
d'urbanisme de politique générale ou en
marketing lorsqu'on lance un nouveau
produit ou qu'on mette en place une
stratégie
posez vous la question est ce que je
ferais cela à cette personne est ce que
j'enverrai cette promotion à cette
personne et donc je vais terminer cette
conférence je vous présente mes marie
lou
de ma grand mère
et j'ai cette fois où il a quelques
années
à peine changé et j'ai cette photo sur
mon bureau j'ai retrouvé cette photo sur
mon bureau celle de ma grand-mère akli
je voulais un amour absolu laineux qui
était la bienveillance absolue et je me
pose toujours la question est ce que est
ce que je lui ferais ça
posez vous cette question avec la
personne que vous aimez le plus et dites
vous est ce que je ferai ça
on fera comme ça tous par évolution
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]